The Real Life Indiana Jones
From the picture in the show notes, you might
mistake Roy Chapman Andrews for Indiana Jones.
In fact, Andrews’ life is like something
out of an Indiana Jones movie, but without
the Nazis.
Not surprising, since it has been widely speculated
that he was the man who Indiana Jones was
based on.
(Although, no one associated with the movies
has officially confirmed this, and it’s
thought by many that the link is indirect,
with Andrews providing the model for many
portrayals of adventurers in 1940s and 1950s
films, which in turn influenced Lucas in his
creation of the character of Indiana Jones).
Born on January 26, 1884 in Beloit, Wisconsin,
Andrews’ fascination with the natural world
started at a young age.
In This Business of Exploring, Andrews later
wrote: “I was born to be an explorer…There
was never any decision to make.
I couldn’t do anything else and be happy.”
He spent his childhood roaming the wilds of
Wisconsin, exploring everything from the woods
to the waterways.
He developed skills as a marksman and as a
taxidermist, and used the money he earned
from the latter hobby to fund his education
at Beloit College.
He started off his career at the American
Museum of Natural History in New York City…
as a janitor.
Not exactly glamorous, right?
But while he was sweeping the floors of the
taxidermy department, he also brought in specimens
to display.
Over the next few years, he worked his way
up in the museum while working toward a Master
of Arts degree in mammalogy (the study of
mammals).
His big break came in 1908 when he was invited
by the museum to travel the world studying
whales.
Andrews jumped at the opportunity.
For the next eight years, he could be seen
on board various whaling ships.
He circled the globe twice while on this particular
adventure, particularly being interested in
finding beaked whales, but they eluded him
in the wild.
Funny enough, he found a beaked whale skeleton
in the Natural History museum’s collections
later, and was able to name it Mesoplodon
bowdoini after the man who funded the whale
trip.
While he was out and about in the ocean, and
in his following years of fieldwork, he ran
into a few life-threatening situations as
you might expect of an explorer/adventurer
in that era, and a man often compared to the
character of Indiana Jones.
Writing in On the Trail of Ancient Man, Andrews
shrugged off his brushes with death:
“In [my first] fifteen years [of field work]
I can remember just ten times when I had really
narrow escapes from death.
Two were from drowning in typhoons, one was
when our boat was charged by a wounded whale,
once my wife and I were nearly eaten by wild
dogs, once we were in great danger from fanatical
lama priests, two were close calls when I
fell over cliffs, once was nearly caught by
a huge python, and twice I might have been
killed by bandits.”
But it wasn’t whales that made Andrews famous
world-wide.
It was a trip to the Gobi desert that did
that.
In 1922, Andrews carried out his first expedition
into the harsh Gobi Desert.
The main goals were to chart the area and
bring back fossils and live creatures, and
perhaps prove the museum director’s theory
that all life stems from Central Asia.
On the expedition, Andrews employed the use
of camels and automobiles to trek across the
desert—an odd combination, and the use of
automobiles in the desert got him called a
“fool”, but in the end it worked.
Between 1922 and 1930, Andrews and his team
went out on five different expeditions into
the region.
In the Gobi desert, “while his paleontologist
used a camel hair brush, Andrews hacked away
with a pickaxe.”
But his “scientific cowboy” methods worked
in this instance; his team found a treasure
trove of large and small dinosaur fossils,
the skull of an early mammal, and, most significantly,
a nest of dinosaur eggs- the first ever found.
Previous to the dinosaur egg find, scientists
had correctly theorized that dinosaurs hatched
from eggs because they were reptiles.
However, this was the first time that they
had solid proof that this was the case.
Because of this, the find was hugely significant
in providing knowledge about how the dinosaurs’
life cycles began.
In all, the expedition recovered 25 dinosaur
eggs and brought them safely back to the museum.
Chapman ended up selling one in an auction
in order to help fund additional trips.
The egg sold for $5000 (about $64.7K today)
to one Mr. Colgate, but the auction also helped
to accumulate over $50,000 in donations.
People wanted to see what other natural history
had been hiding in the Gobi desert for centuries.
But discovering new species of dinosaurs and
dinosaur nests weren’t the only adventures
that Andrews and his team had.
In one notable instance, Andrews was carefully
making his way down a steep, winding road
when he saw a group of bandits waiting for
him at the bottom of the hill.
The bandits were on horseback and wielding
rifles.
Andrews couldn’t go back up the slope—there
was no room to turn around—but letting the
bandits take what they wanted was unacceptable,
as he’d just come back from a supply run.
So what did Andrews do?
In true Indiana Jones form, he decided the
best course of action was to plough straight
through the rifle carrying men at great speed.
The bandits’ horses panicked.
Three of them bolted off with their riders
barely hanging on, unable to reach for their
guns; a fourth remained, and Andrews sidled
up next to it, pulled out his gun, and shot
at the rider’s hat as he scurried after
his fellows
Not only that, but there was also a scary
night when the entire campsite became infested
with deadly snakes!
It was a family of venomous pit vipers—not
exactly the kind of thing you want to see
slithering past your tent flap.
After someone raised the alarm, the team set
to work ridding their campsite of the creatures.
They killed 47 in all.
As for Andrews, at the end of the evening,
he accidentally trod on a long, soft something
near his bed, and screamed.
It turned out to be a coil of rope rather
than a snake.
Luckily for the expedition, everyone emerged
in the morning unscathed—other than perhaps
Andrews’ hurt pride—because the cool temperatures
meant the snakes weren’t at the top of their
game.
Unfortunately, in 1930, the Gobi Desert was
closed off to Andrews.
The Great Depression made it difficult to
raise the funds necessary for such a trip,
and the area had recently been overrun by
communism, meaning Western visitors were generally
unwelcome.
That wasn’t the end for Andrews, though.
In 1934, he became the Director of the American
Museum of Natural History—quite the step
up from the janitor he was back in 1906.
He also served as the president of the Explorer’s
Club in New York from 1931-1934, originally
joining in 1908.
He retired in 1942, and lived in California
until his death in 1960.